tout le monde l'a déjà vu
tu as déclaré comme ce dont je pouvais
pas prendre de long parce que c'est un
facho un trou de balle
Gabin ça te rappelles mélodie en
sous-sol tout ça en fait c'est ta cam ça
vient tout seul l'ancien braqueur il
s'appelle Charles comme toi donc voilà
donc ça fait des braquages tu en as fait
[Rires]
et et
son conjoint dans un parking
voilà tu
fais que ça et ton père est parti en
calèche comme tu dis
heureusement que tu as découvert le
hip-hop
la branche dur dur quand même hein la la
branche non je me suis posé dessus c'est
tout pas les requins vicieux c'est pas
détendre quand même non joyeux petit
compagnon qui
va avoir des problèmes
je voulais que tu voulais je voulais
qu'on je reste concret direct c'est la
guerre en sous les bras tout seul c'est
la vérité sur toi
la respire aussi
alors aujourd'hui tu as la fiche de
banlieue de 13 produits par Luc Besson
magnéto Serge
les gangs règne en maître absolu
quel est le but de prendre les sous
quand on sait qu'on a aucune chance de
réussir voulez je désamorce une bombe
lieu de la pire des bandits dans
laquelle j'ai jamais mis les pieds avec
c'est pas très actif 23h pour mon cette
merde
ce qui concerne les lieux on vous a
trouvé un guide
en plus au travail en tandem
ah non tu sors ton manuel de police qui
regarde à la page suis dans la merde
ta gueule
je te préviens si tu me touches occupé
d'elle
je sais pas en cas de temps ces 5
adolescents
un truc qui cloche dans ton histoire ça
sent l'embrouille
c'est ma bagnole qui est en train de
défoncer la
plus
[Musique]
si c'est pas Monaco c'est pas
invité ce soir ça c'est un vrai film
d'action t'a dit ça frites vraiment
qu'il prenne toute la place
interview bisounours
[Musique]
le petit nounours vous aviez quel âge
pour votre premier bisous
la semaine dernière pourquoi faut parler
non je me suis coincé dans une
la pâquerette et
[Rires]
ben vous avez attendu longtemps votre
virginité une jeune fille
12 ans
c'est quoi la soirée des Halles à deux
pour vous
réveille-moi à 7h pour 100 personnes
vous préférez quand harry rencontre
sally une nuit blanche à Seattle
quelle est la chose la plus romantique
que vous ayez fait dans votre vie
offrir des fleurs
c'est quand la dernière fois qu'une
figure est bien sûr
6 mois
il y a 6 mois voilà elle a fait quoi a
pas fait grand-chose mais elle a fait
ça t'a blessé
c'est un détail pour vous mais
ce soir il est dans la salle ce soir il
fait France Gall
[Rires]
c'est dans les bras vous sentez le mieux
c'est quoi définition de l'amour
je la cherche encore
et votre peluche favorite c'est laquelle
[Rires]
c'est un nounours
un petit un petit bisounours
[Rires]
c'est quel personnage préféré
[Musique]
ça balance pas mal à Paris
jamais osé dire je t'aime
pharmacie
on t'envoie un petit bisou
là.
[Musique]
docteur Morel produit par Luc Besson
je vais je t'emmerde pour être sûr de ne
rien rater
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu